the Joe Rogan experience last time I
felt that was the Tison documentary I'm
strong
it was strong dude there's a time when
he's talking about walking into the ring
that as he steps in the ring all the
nervousness all the things that going
through says and that is his confidence
bills as it gets towards the ring any
steps through the ropes I'm a god what
he says holy God that's that's that's
until second man to me yeah that's the
dough sekiz man to me it's crazy he's
hurting again that's that is the dough
sekiz man to me though most interesting
man in America that Mike Tyson yeah is
that there are so many different levels
and and pieces of death yeah
to Mike Tyson in his story one of the I
mean it's one of the strongest docs I've
ever seen well he's he's one of those
guys one of those super winners that
just I mean when he was young I mean
everyone knows the story but if you
don't
he was basically had no love in his life
until he met custom auto and custom auto
became a father figure but also custom
auto was a hypnotist and a psychologist
in a lot of ways and a fantastic boxing
coach as well and took this young kid
and showed him that you're gonna get
love from accomplishment and you're
gonna conquer and you're gonna become
the greatest heavyweight boxer of all
time and through his tutelage up until
the moment that he died Mike Tyson was
just a just a phenom a thing that we had
never seen before he was the pit bull
with no leash that that respected one
person yes and anybody else at any given
time feared to [ __ ] out of his pit boys
because nobody else knew hey man yeah
who's what is hey yeah somebody gotta
get this hey whoa what yeah what is this
with each other's day if I see Mike this
stood out there's a little nervousness
for no reason for sure
it's not like he's coming in with this
thing like I'm killing it right now but
this is gentle he's a most loving man in
the world you talk to him he's all
spoken but there's still a little thing
like this Michael hit me
my friend Kevin Lee said it best Kevin
Lee fights for the UFC he said when he
said next time he goes he goes that's a
lion it's a lion
okay oh my god you know this this fight
man I just you know wish him the best I
know he's back there's writing and stuff
you know you just want him to be safe
and in and healthy and his time but you
know that's the man I I don't ever count
out but goddamn seeing him just put up
those little displays of terrifying
fighters it's what it's terrifying
heat-seeking missiles coming from his
shoulders well not only that he wasn't
doing anything like a year ago when I
had him in here for the podcast he said
he didn't want to stoke his ego he
didn't want to workout he goes because
if I work out my ego fires up there is
look at this look at this look at this
[ __ ] here but you know that that's
that's interesting but that's just
shadowboxing who was crazy is he's
training with Rafael Cordeiro
who's one of the best MMA trainers one
of the best striking trainers in the
world he came from a legendary camp out
of Brazil Curitiba Brazil called shoot
the box it's like the legendary team of
marauders
from Brazil they were like the the
golden glory days of pride pride was you
know a competitor to the UFC was defined
in a lot of ways the glory days were
defined by this one team from Brazil
that huh feyo caldera was a part of and
then that guy training Mike Tyson now
and he's been super successful training
mixed martial arts fighters too but I
found it very interesting that Mike
chose to train with that guy and to see
the way they're going at it mean he's
not boxing he's trying to destroy
[ __ ] listen you you I respect
the trainer I respect the trainer for
standing in that in the way of that [ __ ]
like that's yes one must one-one
accidental oops
missiles
just missiles no listen uh boom you
gotta just you gotta just bow down you
know and and you know what man that's
we're still in the presence of greatness
and as people I don't I don't think we
should ever forget that
well what's crazy is he's 53 years old
he's doing this and he's only been doing
this again for like less than a year so
it's only been like four or five months
he's really been training hard and
everything is just coming back it's I
mean I wonder I wonder what it is I
wonder if it just was bored I mean I
really wanted this is this is the crazy
[ __ ] Jesus Christ
okay that is Christ if you saw that guy
if you saw that guy training he was a 22
year old kid you like man this
[ __ ] gonna be something because
he's just got an intensity that you
rarely see from any fighter there's a
fury that burns inside of him that you
you can't manufacture that you either
have that or you don't and he found a
way to reach really ignite it I was a I
swear you beat me to it
yeah he beat me to it
[Applause]